Larry Karaszewski:Hi, I’m Larry Karaszewski,
nominated tonight for theTHE PEOPLE v. O.J.
SIMPSON, American Crime Storywith my partner,Scott
Alexander. Film Courage: Larry, obviously
this is not your first story about [someone’s
public and private life], you’ve done films
on filmmaker Ed Wood and Larry Flynt, as well.
What attracted you to this story?
Larry Karaszewski: This story, it’s funny,
because it’s the first time [writing partner]
Scott and I’ve have ever written television
and we basically do movies and we would have
never done this story as a movie, because
as a 2-hour package it would have just been
telling people what they already knew about
the O.J. Simpson trial. Whereas all the
offshoots of it, all of the themes we could
discover inside the piece, whether it’s
gender politics or class relations or birth
of the infotainment culture, you know. And
sort of theblack problemswith the Los
Angeles Police Department. And so there
was so much we could do with this story that
10 hours felt like the proper medium for this
story. Film Courage: Were you in Los Angeles
during the whole [O.J. Simpson] trial and
the Bronco [car] chase?
Larry Karaszewski: Absolutely. I remember
exactly where I was when the Bronco chase
happened. I think we all remember where
we were during the Bronco chase. We were
writing a script for Disney at the time.
And it was before cellphones and all of those
things. And as everyone is leaving the building,
there was a janitor downstairs with a little
black-and-white television and it was like
“O.J. Simpson is being chased!” And
the entire building all circled around the
janitor’s closet and watched the Bronco
chase [on television] in his closet. Film
Courage: Do you remember the day that the
verdict came out and how the feeling around
the City [of Los Angeles]?
Larry Karaszewski: Absolutely. Film Courage:
So how did this [writing] opportunity come
to you? Larry Karaszewski:One of the producers
on the project, named Brad Simpson, was in
a used bookstore and he sawJeffrey Toobin’sbook
[The Run of His Life – The People v. O.
J. Simpson]. And there was this little idea
in Brad’s head like“Maybe I should take
a look at this? Maybe it’s time to revisit
the O.J. Simpson trial?”And he read the
book and it’s a terrific book. Jeffrey
is also nominated tonight. And the great
thing about this particular award show is
they give the person who wrote the book an
award, as well as the person who adapted it.
It was one of those things where we were looking
for a long time what would be the thing [project]
we would do for television. Scott and I
are usually very deliberate about our decision
about the kind of projects we take. And
in a second we were like “Yes!” in the
room there. We want to take on Tobin’s
book.
Film Courage: So from that time that you
met with [producer Brad Simpson] how much
time has passed since you got the show on
the air?
Larry Karaszewski: It was a very long time.
We didn’t treat it like traditional television.
We really developed it and researched it and
so it was about three years until it got on
the air and now about a year since it’s
been on the air. Film Courage: When you
wrote the beginning episode, did you have
other people look at it [the script] for a
tone and making sure that whatever your own
bias was or your [writing] partner’s bias
was not put in to the writing? Larry Karaszewski:
I would say we definitely had other people
take a look at it, but we have our own tone,
so I don’t actually think it was about us
taking our take away from it. We were never
coming right out and saying whether he did
or didn’t do it. But there is so much
evidence that sort of point in that direction.
We were just presenting the case in a very
unusual, satiric, comedic tone but the tricky
thing in this was two innocent people died,
so you never wanted that to be any source
of humor. But there was an absurdity that
was the O.J. Simpson trial and having The
Kardashians be a part of it and things like
that. So we were always conscious of trying
to keep our tone and we always had great advice
and some co-writers with us all the time to
keep us honest. It was very important to
us to tell the truth and do it in an very
entertaining way. Film Courage: I know all
of the legal team became their own celebrity
from it [the trial], Judge Ito included.
How much research did you do [beforehand]
on let’s say [prosecuting attorney] Marcia
Clark or whomever? Larry Karaszewski: We
did an insane amount of research. I mean
there is Jeffrey Toobin’s book but every
single person involved in the trial wrote
at least one, maybe two books, sometimes three
books. There is thousands and thousands
of court transcripts. There are hours of
court TV so it was really just the most intense
research project we ever had. Even the jurors
wrote books.
Film Courage: So when you write a screenplay
do you think that it’s finished after two
drafts? How critical are you of your own
work or your partner’s work? Larry Karaszewski:
Well, we’re very critical of our own work
because by the time it gets to even first
draft, that’s probably actually number ten
for us. We’ve gone through it so many
times. So we generally prefer the earlier
drafts because they are kind of the most pure,
but we’ve been in this business a long time
so we do whatever it takes to get it on the
air.
Film Courage: What book can you recommend
to some of the viewers on screenwriting structure
or adaption, anything? Larry Karaszewski:
I don’t really know? Certainly in the
old days I would read something likeSyd
Field, but I have no idea if that would actually
be something in today’s climate. I’d
recommend a book that we wrote which was about
our screenplay forMAN ON THE MOON, the Jim
Carrey movie about Andy Kaufman. We not
only include the screenplay but we include
a very in-depth, how things change for the
screen and young screenwriters can really
look at that book and understand how a script
changes from when you write it until it makes
it on the screen. Film Courage: And lastly,
what film impacted you in terms of a true
crime movie, like an Errol Morris film say
THE THIN BLUE LINE, different films in a similar
genre to what you’ve done here? Larry Karaszewski:
I mean as a young man I saw the black and
white version ofIN COLD BLOOD, Richard Brooks’
version of that. And that definitely had
a gigantic effect on me, it terrified me.
So that was the first thing that came to mind.
CertainlyDavid Fincher’s ZODIACis an
extraordinary film, because it’s about not
solving the crime and it’s about how unsettling
that is. The fact that no matter how horrific
true crime stories tend to be, at the end
there is some kind of closure and ZODIAC is
about not getting that closure. And what
that does to a person. How it tears you
apart. So it’s a very interesting film.
Film Courage: Great! Thank you very much.
I appreciate your time.
Larry Karaszewski: Thank you! Erik Oleson:Hi,
I’m Erik Oleson. I’m here fromTHE MAN
IN THE HIGH CASTLE. Film Courage: Erik, how
many years did it take to get this television
show made and how did it finally happen?
Erik Oleson:I was hired to join the show
for season two. Well, I know from the novel
which was written decades ago [author Philip
K. Dick], the original producers of the series
struggled for many, many years to bring it
to the screen. It was a long development process,
over a decade. So I was fortunate enough to
be brought on in season two. Film Courage:
Had you already watched the show? Erik Oleson:Oh
yes! I’d watched all of season one. And
I came on board and ended up being the head
writer of season two. Film Courage: Do you
remember when you sat down to write for them?
I don’t know if you prepared a spec script
for them or what the process was? What was
the first presentation of your work to the
show’s developers? Erik Oleson:Well, I
had written on 15 other television shows series
prior to THE MAN IN THE HIGH CASTLE, so my
work was kind of known. I’m also an executive
producer so they knew I could handle a lot
of the other aspects that go along with writing
a big television show like this. But the thing
that I’d written that probably put me most
in contention, I’d written a pilot about
Nazi occupied Paris, which was a historically
based pilot. So I think a lot of the folks
read that and said“He knows how to do
a Nazi show.” Film Courage: What are your
first steps for writing a screenplay? Do you
have a set of tried-and-true set of rules
that you use? Or is every script different?
Erik Oleson:My process evolves every time
I do another job. I realize how much I didn’t
know in my prior job. So I’m someone who
reads pretty much every trick, every screenwriting
book, every script that I can get my hands
on and I’m constantly trying to evolve as
a craftsman. I am also fortunate enough in
this job to surround myself with really talented
people and you learn a lot from other writers.
There were writers on THE MAN IN THE HIGH
CASTLE that won Emmys, or Martin Scorsese’s
best friend…you really want to kind of learn
from the people around you and that makes
you better. So I can’t say that I have any
set process, although right now I have to
say I’m a big fan ofthe John Truby stuff.
I think he kind of hits the sweet spot for
me. But I’ve taken them all. I’ve taken
[Robert] McKee. I’m one of these guys who
likes to learn new stuff about the craft and
think if I can learn something from any book,
if I can learn one thing from it and it makes
me a better writer, I’m all for it. Film
Courage: Have you ever written a screenplay
that has no structure?
Erik Oleson:I am more of a planner than
a “pantser.” Obviously likeStephen Kingwill
say he swears by the seat-of-your-pants approach.
But I’m much more of an outliner, an engineer
when it comes to that. And you throw that
out and you let the character speak to you
and gather the moment and things change. But
I’m also a big fan of structure I have to
say. So no, I haven’t sat down and tried
to write a final product from page one. I
kind of construct it over time. I’m a grinder
I guess you could say. Film Courage: When
you begin to write, are you envisioning the
people watching the final product or does
that not even enter into your mind? You’re
so involved with the beginning and what’s
in your own head? Erik Oleson:You want to
keep the audience in mind somewhat but you
also don’t want to pander. Like, if you’re
in the moment, much as an actor is in the
moment, you’re trying to find the humanity
and the truth behind what you’re writing
about. And whether you’re doing a superhero
show, whether you’re doing a big, deep,
socio-political show like THE MAN IN THE HIGH
CASTLE you actually find yourself lost in
the moment and how the characters are speaking
to each other as real people and that’s
the joy of discovery that happens when you
have enough (for me) of the structure figured
out that you have the correct characters in
the scene. You’re in the moment and they
start to talk to you when it works. Film Courage:
Well speaking of talking, this will be my
last question but with dialogue, how much
are you refining the dialogue and making sure
that you’re researching it for that specific
time period and trying it out on other people?
Erik Oleson:Constantly. There is a constant
polish process that goes on for dialogue.
Also, we had researchers who were making sure
that we didn’t use words that didn’t exist
and sometimes they would catch us making an
anachronistic, modern kind of “Oh yeah.
That doesn’t work. We have to change the
line.” Because we all are creatures of pop
culture, as well. In THE MAN IN THE HIGH CASTLE,
which takes place in the early 1960’s, I
had to avoid references from some of my favorite
superheroes. Film Courage: Any other terminology,
I mean definitely not using the word “Bro.”
That’s become part of the culture. Were
there certain things in the 1960’s that
we don’t even realize it wasn’t part of
the vernacular? Erik Oleson:Correct. In
the case of THE MAN IN THE HIGH CASTLE it’s
an alternative world also where history has
turned out differently from the tale of World
War II, so a lot of the language that we would
use in a first draft kind of would be slightly
different like given the way the world turned
out and cultural experience. And in THE MAN
IN THE HIGH CASTLE, white people are not the
overclass in the Pacific States. They are
kind of treated as an oppressed minority and
so there are all sorts of textures that seed
into the language when you have that kind
of story. So it’s an alt-history storyline
and language was very important to us and
we had a lot of very smart people making sure
that we were polishing it up right to the
moment the cameras rolled.
Film Courage: Excellent! Thank you, Erik.
Erik Oleson:Thank you! Margot Lee Shetterly:
Hello, my name is Margot Lee Shetterly and
I am the author of HIDDEN FIGURES. Film Courage:
How long did it take to write and then sell
the book? Margot Lee Shetterly: All told
it took about six years. A little less than
six years, actually. I started working on
it in December of 2010. I really did about
three years of research before I put together
a book proposal, finding an agent and then
finding a publisher. So I submitted the
final draft of this book in July of this year.
And the book was published in September, a
couple months before the movie came out. Film
Courage: So then how did the movie come
about? How was it discovered and who wanted
to take it on.  I know Theodore Melfi [and
Allison Schroeder] did the screenplay (the
adaptation). Margot Lee Shetterly: My literary
agent is Mackenzie Brady Watson and some how
it landed on the desk of Donna Gigliotti who
is the producer of the movie. So Donna called
me up and remember this was only a book proposal
this time. It was like three years ago and
I hadn’t finished the book. She saw the
book proposal and she said “We are going
to make a movie of this story.” And I
thought “Well, geez. I’m still writing
the book. It’s not even a book. You
want to option my book proposal? I’d never
written a book before.” But she believe
in that story. She really took a flyer on
a first time writer/author and now the rest
is history. Everything that she said on
this first phone call has come true. Film
Courage: I know HIDDEN FIGURES is a true
story that many did not know of before it
came out. What movie did you see which had
the same type of impact that I’m sure many
people will feel once they see the film [HIDDEN
FIGURES]? Margot Lee Shetterly: Wow! That’s
a hard question. There are so many movies
that are amazing and inspirational. You
kind of put me on the spot here. Film Courage:
[Laughs] Sorry! Margot Lee Shetterly: You
know, I’d have to think about it. In general
the thing about HIDDEN FIGURES, even though
it is a work of non-fiction, it is totally
a work of imagination, you know? And I think
the thing about movies that you do remember
and that do inspire you is that they do spark
your imagination and I think that is the reason
people are responding so strongly is that
they see something in these women that says
to them “Wow! I just expanded my imagination
of what the world looks like and who I might
be.” Film Courage: And you would hear
them [the women working at NASA] speaking
to you, in your own way? In your research
that you did on them….did you hear their
voices? Margot Lee Shetterly: I did! It’s
so funny that you asked that question. I
found myself talking to them, having conversations
with them and dreaming about them, and thinking
about them. I looked at photos of them to
see what they looked like at different parts
of their life. I listened to their children
talk about the gestures. Like Dorothy Vaughan.
When she got upset would start putting her
finger on the table and everybody knew to
back off, you know? And that she was really,
like a fearless kind of a woman. I knew
all of these different things about them until
I felt that they had really come back to life
and that they were my friends. And they
really were. They become my companions.
Of course in the case of Katherine Johnson,
she is 98-years-old and she is very much still
with us. And I had an incredible privilege
to spend time interviewing her and getting
to know her life firsthand. Film Courage:
Excellent! Thank you! Best of luck and
you look beautiful! Margot Lee Shetterly:
Thank you!
Film Courage: Saroo, from the beginning
of when you wrote your book [A Long Way Home:
A Memoir] until now, how long of a process
was this?
Saroo Brierley: 2012? April I think?
So this is 2017, so four years? Four and
a half years. But it took me a year to write
the book. So I was pretty fast. Film Courage:
Okay. And then how did you present the book
for adaption for [screenwriter] Luke (Davies)
to write it? Or how did that whole process
turn out. Saroo Brierley: The process was
Luke read the book and then I said to Cecil
Films and then I said I’ve got to get Luke
to India and take him through the journey
that I went through and I thought that would
give him another dimension of feel and atmosphere
that you would sort of get from reading a
book so and I wanted to take him back from
right where it started. Do the train journey
and all the places that I went to. And then
come to Australia and see if it rings true
as well. Because I think if I didn’t do
that, it wouldn’t have had clarity. It
wouldn’t be sort of as clean and it would
really sort of help him in terms of writing
the script.
Film Courage: For me LION has been my favorite
narrative film for the year and I’m not
just saying this because you’re in front
of me here. I’m really excited to tell
others about it and I have. The whole package
is beautiful with the music and everything.
For you, I’m wondering what is an inspiring
film that has touched your life as LION has
touched mine. It can be from any year.
It does’t have to be this one [2016-17]?
Saroo Brierley: It’s very relevant actually
to LION and it’s this other movie. It’s
called the JOY LUCK CLUB. I don’t know
if you’ve heard of it? Particularly, where
the mother and the children meet in the room
there…..and at the end of the movie, I meet
my mother and it’s very touching to me.
I have a very soft spot for that movie.
But it’s an amazing movie that I saw at
a young age and remember it still to this
day. Film Courage: So when you saw that
film and you began working with Luke Davies
on the screenplay [for LION], did you want
people to come away with the same feeling,
or a similar feeling, or really because it
was about your life you were not able to remove
yourself? Since that movie impacted you,
did you want others to be impacted, as well?
Film Courage: Well of course I would have.
That was up to Luke to make that variation
of that certain situation with Garth to make
it come alive so I guess that’s such a pivotal
point in the movie as well that particular
bit, reuniting together mother and son.
I think that the way Luke has done it is really,
really amazing and really wanted to get down
to the grass roots and more particularly that
sort of scene because apparently that was
the first scene shot and I couldn’t believe
it when he told me. But a lot of people
were particularly enthralled with this scene
because it would resonate with a lot of people
especially mothers and people who have lost
their mothers as well. But I think that
it touches me overtime that I see it.
Film Courage: What book for you has been
instrumental in the creative process, in writing
for you. What book [can you recommend] on
writing, creativity? Saroo Brierley: That’s
a hard one because I’ve only been really
reading magazines and comics and sometimes
reading Mum’s beauty magazines, Cosmopolitan
and a few others but I’m a first time author
and I’ve never written a book. And I went
from being into industrial retail sales to
just landing in this…to just doing this
journey but all the sudden becoming an author
and having been asked to write my memoir.
Film Courage: And I understand you are working
with your Mom on a second book. Is that
right? Saroo Brierley: How did you know?
Film Courage: I heard it in another video…A
little birdie told me. Saroo Brierley: Yeah…we
are. We’re about to start the prequel
to LION or A LONG WAY HOME. Which doesn’t
really have to do so much with me but coming
to the point just prior to me which has mostly
to do with mothers, my adopted mother and
my biological. And also one more lady which
is Saroj Sood who owns the orphanage and how
those women are all interrelated. And all
for the one cause, the humanitarian side to
help others that are more in need. And I’m
just getting goose bumps just talking about
it. It is so unique to have women from oceans
apart from different backgrounds all wanting
to do one thing and that is to help a child
and to give him or her another chance of life.
Saroo Brierley: Well I could stay here all
night and talk with you but I know you have
to go. But last question and that is for people
of an adult age who have a childhood that
either they don’t remember or there are
lots of unanswered questions and they’re
adults. What would you recommend to them
about either going home or trying to find
out more about their own history so that they
know who they are, [and have] a sense of
themselves? Saroo Brierley: I’m not too
sure but for me it was finding closure.
And for them I think it was about listening
to your heart and listening to your dreams
really. Because that is what it was for
me. In a nutshell, encapsulated. And if
they are longing for something that has been
lost for such a long time and it’s such
a weight on their shoulders then they ought
to pursue it. Because life is a little bit
difficult when you don’t know your identity
and you don’t know your past because…but
give it a valiant attempt and at least try
to get answers and closure to something that
you can’t get answers to because if you
don’t try then you don’t know.
Film Courage: Well thank you and good luck
tonight, Saroo! Constanza Romero: I’m
Constanza Romero and I’m here representing
my late husband August Wilson. He did the
film adaptation for FENCES and he also wrote
the original play which played on Broadway
in 1984, 1985 and in 2010 with Denzel Washington.
Film Courage: Tell us about what you saw
in his (August’s) work ethic and how he
would dive into a story. How did he create
a world on the page? Constanza Romero: Well
his work ethic was this: to live was to
work. And to work was to live. He was
always working. He was always developing
his characters. If we say down to eat he,
was talking about his work and his characters
were like almost real, you know? He would
tell me what a character was doing and I was
like “Oh, my God. He robbed a bank?”
So how he developed it, he wrote in long hand
and then he transferred it to the computer
and then he would always talk in his rhythm.
Until it sounded good in his ear he wouldn’t
finalize it yet because he was all about…his
poetry was his music and if it didn’t sound
right to his ear, he rewrote it and rewrote
it. And that is where you can see where
he was a poet first.
Film Courage: What can you share with our
viewers about being so close to someone that
is so involved in the creative process and
in some sense you are sharing your life with
another entity and that is their work? Constanza
Romero: Well, I’m a costume designer so
we collaborated on a lot of projects. I
would be sort of his visual dramaturge so
to speak because I would find different photos
that were inspirational to him while they
were inspirational to me too because I was
doing the costumes and he would also say the
lines out loud and I would read his first
scripts and I would say “Well, what about
this character? Could she be this or could
she be that?” And so the collaboration
process was really incredible. But sometimes
it was a little too much. As I said, we
would be downstairs eating and he would go
on, and on, and on, and on, about the play
and I would just say “Oh! I’ve got to
go to work.” And he’d follow me up the
stairs and eat a sandwich right by my drawing
table….but it’s all just good memories.
Film Courage: Any of the characters or one
specific character that was most like him
in some sense? Constanza Romero: Oh….you
know…I have to say that all of the characters
are like him and although the character of
Rose is definitely inspired by his mother.
But I think that this is the amazing breadth
of his work is that all his characters had
little part of himself but they were also
so imaginatively created. So I can’t say
that there is one person. For example when
he was young, he was the older son whose art
nobody understood, you know? Because he
was writing poetry on napkins and menus.
So the older son Lyons [in FENCES] he was
sort of like him carrying around his pen and
paper like he carries around his instrument
and playing at night but nobody in his family
understanding why the heck they don’t get
a job. Right! Yes! Film Courage: And lastly,
what can you tell others about what it’s
like to share your life with someone who at
some points maybe they are critical of their
own work? And watching them go through days
that maybe they didn’t feel good about their
projects even though others related to them
but it was such a tough process because they
were so close to the material and couldn’t
see it for what it was? Constanza Romero:
Yeah…August hated to cut. If somebody
said the play is longer than three hours,
what are we going to do? So I think that
he would be so stubborn, nobody could make
him cut something. And then finally one
of the producers set me aside and said “Can
you tell him that Seven Guitars is a little
too long.” And actually I sat down and
I could really see where it could be snipped
here and there and I was able to help him
do that. But I believe I was one of the
only people he really trusted to tell him
the truth as you’re saying. And not every
day was inspired, not every day was a joy.
Creating something is not always a joyful
process.  It has a lot of raw emotions and
you are practically weaving gold. But the
raw material is not always the gold that it
becomes later.
Film Courage: Beautiful! Thank you! Howard
A. Rodman: Hi, I’m Howard Rodman.
I’m president of the Writer’s Guild West
and also Chair of the 2017 USC Scripter Selection
Committee. Film Courage:  We’re curious
what you would recommend to beginning writers
on trying to present their first screenplay
or protect their work. What are some of
the few things you recommend? Howard A. Rodman:
First thing I recommend to beginning writers
is that the only way that I absolutely guarantee
that you will not have a career as a writer
is to quit. So what I recommend to beginning
writers is, real simple, real basic, is that
you write every day in terms of getting our
work out there in the world. If you’re
shy or a shoegazer, you have to be aggressive
on behalf of your work and get it into the
hands of anyone who might conceivably read
it, as painful and humiliating as that process
is.
In terms of protecting your work you should
absolutely copyright it. Put the C in the
circle. Get the form from the U.S. Copyright
Office. The forms are online. It’s really
simple. And also register with the Writer’s
Guild. The two give very complimentary protections
for work for new people.
Film Courage: You are a writer, as well?
You’ve written screenplays? Can you share
with us the first film that inspired you to
want to write?
Howard A. Rodman: I’m a writer. See
the calluses [holds up his hands to the camera].
And there are so many films that inspired
me to want to write that to pick one I think
would be crazy. But I think I remember there
is a scene at the opening of an old Film Noir
boxing movie called BODY AND SOUL, I believe
written by Abraham Lincoln Polonsky, Directed
by Robert Rossen. And there is a boxer,
a very proud, sort of first generation, scrappy
immigrant boxer played by John Garfield and
the mob boss is offering him a lot of money
not to win the fight. All the money has
been bet the other way. And John Garfield
starts talking about his pride and his morals
and the ethics of throwing a fight and the
mob boss turns to him and says “There is
addition. There is subtraction. The rest
is conversation.” And I just thought “Wow!
If I could just like write one of those!”
And I think for many of us we start reading
books and watching movies because somebody
has built a world and we can just hide in
that world for awhile and then you realize.
“Oh, wait! I could build me own sort of
purpose-built world that would really fit
me.” And so the transition from movie
going to reading to writing I think for many
of us is just a slow descent into the pit.
Film Courage: So the first screenplay that
you wrote did you have the similar sort of
dream that this was going to be the first
ONE and it would put you on the map? Like
so many new writers think that the first screenplay
will open doors. Actually even the first
draft [of a first screenplay]. Howard A. Rodman:
I never had any thoughts like that. I
spent well over a decade writing unpublishable
novels before I transitioned to writing unproduceable
screenplays. So I was under no illusion.
I just started having ideas that were movies
that weren’t quite books. And the first
of those screenplays that I wrote still has
not been produced but I’ve gotten tons and
tons of work off of it. It’s like of course
“We can’t do this because it’s too weird,
BUT maybe you can do that?” And so I don’t
think I ever really expected frankly that
anything I wrote would ever be filmed. And
when things I write do get filmed, it just
strikes me as sort of the bonus rounds in
a pinball game. It’s sort of unexpected
and really lovely. Film Courage: Wrapping
up here. I know you have to go.  Wondering
what you see as the most common mistakes or
somethings new writers should be weary of
regarding formatting, structure, things like
that?
Howard A. Rodman: I would tell beginning
writers not to worry too much about about
formatting and structure. In terms of formatting
there are many really good software programs
and some of them you can get for free and
so let them worry about the formatting.
In terms of the structure, I think you can’t
say “My God! My first act didn’t end
on page 29. I’m a bad writer” if you
find real living characters through telling
a story that only you can tell or write about
a place in the world that you know better
than anybody else, just let the story tell
itself, or let the characters tell the story
and the rest will fall into place. Film Courage:
So in other words, for lack of a better term,
get the vomit draft, please excuse my crass
analogy, but get that out and worry about
all the other things later? Howard A. Rodman:
No, I wouldn’t even say that. I would
say…I was the editor-in-chief of my college
newspaper. And there is a big sign in the
newspaper office underneath this huge clock,
that had a blood red second hand and the sign
said “This is a daily, not a weekly.”
And whenever we were there past midnight the
managing editor would put up another sign
that would say “Don’t get it right, get
it written.” And I would say the same
thing to anyone starting out writing and to
people who have been writing all of their
lives. Film Courage: I love it! Thank
you!